i love canceling plans i don't think
there's anything
there's no better relief you feel like
when you have something yeah
you know like last night had you had a
dinner you had to go through after
everything
that you went through yesterday if you
had something you had to go to
you would have been there the point
comes like an hour before we're like
dude
i don't want to go actually stay home
yeah and like the greatest relief in the
world
is when you make up your mind that you
don't give a [ __ ] you're canceling oh
yeah like after that then you're just
like oh we're not going oh you know but
it's like that when you're stressing
about having to go
and you decide to cancel it's like it's
better than any drug in the world dude
damn that is interesting that is a real
high canceling no question because
especially if you have a good excuse
especially if you do yeah i had a great
one yeah
i was like dude i've been in a
yeah i've been in an intervention i
would say that yeah that's a gravy one
usually i'm like hey i'm tired right
yeah
you know you just sound like a [ __ ]
like it's not
yeah i ever have soul was ty we're in
there like pleading you know and they
said it was like three hours and it was
um
it was good but it just and then when
you come up with the l and the
intervention you're like damn you want
to get the squad together how do we
regroup who do we send in next time
should we have done matching outfits
like how do we get this right you know
do we need a baritone like what do we
need
to pull off the solid intervention and
then had you had a dinner last night and
you'd been able to cancel or cancel this
podcast today you'd been like [ __ ] yeah
i'm chilling i got the whole day to just
screw off now which are the others those
are the best days that's my weed pin
dude yeah right there canceling
canceling yeah dude it's a it's a hidden
gem among people who are very busy bro
that's a great you should do like
sometimes one of your buddies is
flipping out about something you have to
do take his phone and be like hey i'm
not coming we're not [ __ ] going yeah
dude i i i look forward to it all the
time and then you know like it's it's a
blessing and a curse right it's good to
be busy yeah it means you got some [ __ ]
going on some people are expecting you
to be somewhere it's a good thing right
but sometimes i'm just like
[ __ ] dude i'm not going yeah i don't
even have an excuse yeah i'm just not
[ __ ] going dang i can't make it
mm-hmm sorry about it oh that's
beautiful sorry about it it's my dad's
birthday yeah he's not a dad's birthday
yeah i want to make that a license plate
on a car i'm like a cool corvette
make it my dad's birthday so
just so you always be like what's what
does that mean oh it's my dad's birthday
sorry yeah
it's the greatest excuse
dude that is a great excuse man wow
thanks bro yeah now i feel much more
relaxed honestly
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two options
watch one this one or this one